hello rejects it is Greg here making
sure the microphone is on it is on I
just got back from a weekend getaway
trip when with a really close friend of
mine a really hot friend of mine super
sexy friend of mine so I'm gonna watch
the gardens the galaxy vol 2 official
trailer number one Here I am late as
[ __ ] to watching this I just got back
literally just got back like a minute
ago you know some people are like why
did you shoot while you're out there I'm
the kind of guy that's like when I'm on
a trip with someone I don't want to
bring work with me why would I do that
that's that's that's a way to disconnect
from the experience of being on a
[ __ ] trip so for you people who are
loaded you just filming and getting on
my ass about it on Twitter um yeah go
you know star-lord yourself here now for
you lovely subs that still watch the
video even though it's not as you know
relevant even though it's only been a
couple days
whoa fate of the universe lies in your
shoulders now whatever you do push this
button cuz that will set off the bomb
immediately and we'll all be dead
ha ha ha in fact what I just said oh no
that's the but never kill everyone let's
try again
Conkel mm-hmm uh-huh
taking car alarm outside
Wow
oh damn
[Music]
not a single person has hey you have an
atomic bomb in your bag if anybody's
gonna oh no no that's a really bad sign
oh wow give me touch someone I can feel
their feelings your feel yeah yeah I
guess yeah I feel a general unselfish
love for you somebody wrong
sexual no no I don't know everyone you
deepest darkest secret do come on I
think you're overreacting alone you
buzzed me so bad that was a pretty
[ __ ] hilarious trailer man that was
really funny baby grew looks so
incredibly adorable I am just so in love
with the baby Groot already yeah oh man
I'm watching what could Rock a raccoon I
only saw carnage the galaxy part 1 in
the theaters opening night that one time
but you know rocker raccoons always been
looking after it rude and was watching
and take care of baby drew it was gonna
be some joyful because I really feel
like we're gonna get it like a kind of
fatherly quality of rocket racoon he
kind of reminds me of like a Bill burr
was a father I really love that this
trailer isn't so not heavy on plot I
know James guns I recently said that he
wants to keep the trailer still like
mysterious like they're not building
this the trailer so far as like what is
the plot exactly what is the mystery of
it you when the trailers all said and
done you're like I actually have no idea
what this movie is really all about or
what the plots really gonna play out
like so I feel like we're gonna be in
for a nice couple surprises because
right now they're showing us a lot of
what we love which is the comedy of the
guardians of the galaxy all the
interaction with baby Groot and Rocket
Raccoon was really funny that last scene
I think that character is mantis that I
don't know that actresses name that
chick is in the old boy remake exactly
now the Mantis character works but I
think her design is so wonderful and
hadn't seen the face that has showed us
at the end was hilarious but the effects
I think I remember I saw like an article
about like a Billis I think is the name
I would be wise to just look it up on
Google right now but I think the name is
a Billis the octopus I like Drax is
flying into at the beginning they look
pretty [ __ ] scary like all them
ballet
Kreacher look really terrified actually
I mean it seems like it's amped up
everything to another level I hope that
it still does a great job in just pure
good character storytelling because I
really appreciate that about the first
Gardens of galaxy that well it's a
massive space epic kind of film I still
thought that we got a really good sense
of each members of the guardians and so
yeah watching Rocket Raccoon and Groot
work work together well I feel like Drax
like I think they're really amping up
his comedy material here I feel like in
this one star-lord and Gamora probably
is gonna tie the knot in some way I mean
that a marriage but I feel like there
apply and in a way where they do get
together officially but what I love
about this trailer like I said is like
it's not heavy on plot so I can't really
comment too much what it's doing a great
job though is showing us that the life
and the spirit of the film is still
there that the characters that we like
we're tuning in we're gonna all return
to hang out with the guardians of the
galaxy again yes a lot of us are excited
for like Kurt Russell in the movie and
such but the trailer still just doing a
great job of going we know that with a
great first movie what you really need
to be sure of is that the characters you
love that will makes them so amazing is
still going to be present and I feel
like that that is very much evident in
this trailer that they just released
yeah no matter what I say about like
we're viewing this trailer I know I'm
gonna go [ __ ] watch it so I can't
really say much more it's not really
heavy gonna plot I feel like this is
just reassuring me that yeah if you love
guardians of the galaxy you're probably
going to love this film as well because
they're still doing the characters
justice and you know how this isn't just
like the best comedy scenes out of the
movie I doubt it cuz the first one's
filled with laughter throughout so I'm
sure that these are not just the best
moments and I feel like there's still so
many more surprises to come I'm very
excited for this film alright rejects
are for new the channel subscribe today
get accepted good do my best to be more
on time with videos and let's give a
shout out to Tom Cruise who's in this
new mommy movie just the trailer I'm
gonna watch right now